now that the engagement of gwen stefani
and blake shelton is instagram official
they must hurry up and do it and stay
married
for the good of the nation
because if there is one thing america
needs right now it is a symbol of
reconciliation
between red and blue america
now a month ago the tabloids were filled
with disturbing stories about the
imminent breakup of this handsome
charismatic couple and it
shook me to my core
it's true us weekly reported the pair's
opposing
political views have become a big
problem which i could have predicted
he's a good old boy from oklahoma and
sings about trucks and beer and things
that happen down by the river
and she's the pop princess hollaback
girl from california of course they
voted for different people i don't know
that for a fact i just know it's true
come on she's whole foods he's piggly
wiggly
she grew up playing punk he grew up
hunting skunk
she stands in line to vote he stands in
line to dance
she thinks guns are crazy he thinks the
best cheese comes in a can
just the fact that they're together is
almost
shakespearean rodeo and julia
[Music]
but but they make it work
because they see each other as more than
just who they voted for
their biggest issue with the person
sleeping next to them isn't party
affiliation it's untreated sleep apnea
and they say yes we're different but
that's also more fun
and we're going to make that work for us
they see the world differently and they
love each other
what a concept i'd like to try it
i'd like to try it in america because
that's how i feel about
my country you complete me alabama
because you complete me does it mean
because we're exactly alike it means
because we are
different i don't want to live in a
country without the red states
i like traveling there when people talk
to you in oklahoma
they're not scanning the room to see if
there's someone more important
because frankly when i'm there there
never is
[Music]
also they laugh like nobody's watching
they don't have a non-dairy gluten-free
hypoallergenic stick up their ass
even the pro-lifers will laugh at a good
dead baby joke
well look i'm pro-choice
but i also get it that a fetus is
irrefutably becoming a human life
so can i see why some people think
you are actually the one who's
deplorable
yes i can so let's all stop doing that
let's all stop seeing each other as
deplorable
wednesday biden said we have to stop
treating our opponents
as enemies look at this guy
do you think he's a racist i don't
and i don't think gwen stefani would
marry one
one out of ten trump voters voted for
obama
i doubt if blake shelton was one of them
but that's okay we don't all see the
world the same way
get over it during the campaign there
was a lot of talk about who can unite us
no president can unite us we have to
unite ourselves
there are only two ways this country can
go either
we come together and forgive our
differences or we turn
into the balkans for decades
sarajevo yugoslavia was a diverse city
where
serbs croats and muslims lived together
as friendly neighbors in 1984 they
hosted the olympics
eight years later people were getting
shot by snipers when they went out for
milk
don't tell me it can't happen here if
trump has taught us
anything it's that it can't happen here
is a terribly
outdated phrase it not only can happen
here
it kind of is happening here people were
afraid in this election to
display lawn signs for the candidate of
their choice
if it was in a neighborhood where that
was a decidedly minority opinion
that's like gang neighborhoods where you
dare not get caught wearing the wrong
color
now more than ever we need an example of
cross-cultural love
to send a message to our broken nation
that love can lift us up where we belong
like a majestic eagle soaring above the
fray and
[ __ ] all over the haters below
and that is why i say for the sake of
the nation gwen
blake you have to make this work
god serious it would be psychologically
devastating if you
are one symbol of america's two halves
coming together
[ __ ] the bet on this so don't get
married
do it quickly and make it stick forever
no pressure
you